new concerns about a post-holiday surge
of the coronavirus
as the nation hits yet another high in
the ongoing fight against the illness
the u.s now leads the world with more
than 13 million
infections there were more than 205 000
new infections just on friday a new
single day high
just shy of 90 000 people are now in the
hospital
there were more than 1400 deaths pushing
the american death toll even closer
to 265 thousand los angeles
county the nation's largest issued a new
stay-at-home order
and a panel of health experts is due to
meet to discuss
how to distribute the initial supply of
a covid19 vaccine
michael george begins our coverage here
in new york this morning michael good
morning
dana good morning holiday shopping is
underway pandemic or not
and across the country there were
incidents of people skirting safe
distancing guidelines on black friday
leaving health care professionals
bracing for the worst
spiraling cases have already put more
than 90 thousand people in the hospital
even before the shopping began 66 year
old shelly dunn
is one of them and lucky enough to be
able to talk
it's really frightening i thought an
asthma attack was frightening
stories from people struggling to stay
alive
are still not deterring holiday shoppers
and gatherers
or giving health care workers a break we
will not get a reprieve because then
christmas comes and then new year times
so if we're just stacking search upon
surge upon surge
i am significantly worried about that
before thanksgiving
32 states saw increases in new daily
covid cases
with pennsylvania arkansas and
massachusetts breaking records
and in oklahoma the officials are
getting pushback from the nurses
association
after it decided to allow nurses who
test positive
to work it is a mixed message to the
public
to allow asymptomatic coded positive
nurses
physicians and other health care workers
to work but in vermont governor phil
scott told residents of his state
social gatherings have consequences if
you are going to have a
gathering with with households outside
of
your household we are asking you
to be to tell us
that that you shouldn't send your kids
to school next week
that you should quarantine your kids for
at least seven days get a test
the county of los angeles banned public
and private gatherings for anyone
outside a household
the religious services and protests can
take place
because they're protected by the
constitution and a 10 pm curfew in san
antonio
another attempt to slow the spread has
been disparaged by bar and restaurant
owners
it is nonsense and it's not fair to the
citizens of san antonio
they're grown adults that can make their
own decisions about whether they gather
and how they gather
as people continue to play tug of war
with the coronavirus
the vaccine is expected to get another
push down the fast track tuesday
when the centers for disease control
holds an emergency meeting
and at that emergency meeting advisors
will vote on who should get the vaccine
first
health experts say that priorities
should be given to frontline workers
those with existing medical conditions
and people over 65. yesterday the fdny
recommended to its members that they be
vaccinated as well when the vaccine is
available
ed michael george here in the big apple
michael thank you